ukraine and russia have agreed on
humanitarian quarters to evacuate
thousands of civilians eastern regions
of ukraine are bracing for a new russian
offensive there more than a hundred
thousand people are believed trapped in
the city of maria paul which has been
under intense bombardment for weeks
local officials have said as many as 5
000 civilians may have been killed in
that city ukrainians are fleeing the
eastern donbass region which has been
partially controlled
by russian-backed separatists since
2014.
now satellite images show a convoy of
hundreds of russian military vehicles
heading for the donbus region and that's
making the evacuation of civilians all
the more urgent
and our correspondent rebecca ritters
has seen what some of that evacuation
looks like rebecca thanks for joining us
what is first of all the latest from
the luhans that region that's part of
donbass in the east
well we are starting to see come to
fruition what we've been expecting the
regrouping of russian troops and the the
pivot towards to focus on the south east
of the of ukraine
and the the south and the east
including luhansk and donetsk as you
just mentioned uh luhansk it's it's
prompted a
more
a stronger effort to get people out of
there luhan's governor has
basically told everyone to get out while
they still can um unfortunately not
everyone is heeding that warning there
is still apparently 30 percent of people
staying in lahars i actually met a guy
who was reporting down in the region
close to near there and i spoke to a
gentleman at the train station and he he
broke down in tears as he was describing
to me uh that some of his friends from
the luhansk and yes region were actually
choosing to stay they'd already lost
everything in the battle in 2014 and
they weren't going to leave again they
said if the russians come in they're
just going to fight them and he he was
really obviously very upset i mean
everyone has seen the pictures from
mariupol as you just mentioned and uh
also around kiev in butcher and nobody
wants those kind of atrocities happening
to their towns and villages william
rebecca you're also in nipro um another
city it's in central eastern uh ukraine
and it's become something of a hub for
internally displaced ukrainians what did
you see there
well nepro is a transport hub in that
region it services the south and the
south east we were at the train station
doing some reporting yesterday and we
saw thousands of people evacuating
thousands of people have already come
through there and they're expecting
thousands more the situation of course
was pretty tense yesterday because it
was just shortly after a day after the
um that bombing at the train station in
kramatorsk which was just 200 or so
kilometers from nepal so authorities
were on really high alert there
yesterday really worried that a similar
attack might take place there a lot of
the people i spoke to just work had come
from the the regions that we're speaking
about those lehigh donets regions but
they just had no idea where they were
going to end up there is a shelter there
people are providing support for the
people that come through there but
they're not really able to stay in nepro
either the mayor of nepro has ordered
all women and children to leave the area
because they're worried that the
fighting is going to also reach that
city
it's difficult to imagine just what
people are facing as they're trying to
find some semblance of safety in ukraine
and you saw some of that traveling back
to la viv where you are now by train
which a lot of people are using
what kind of experience did you have
what what kind of people did you come
across on that journey
well it was an incredibly bittersweet
experience really i mean you see
a relief in some faces but on the other
side you see the sadness they're having
to leave people behind you so we saw you
know people we were on the train with
waving to their loved ones on the
platform who were both relieved that
their relatives were getting to safety
but obviously not knowing when or if
they're going to see them again so
obviously uh you know there was a lot of
sadness on the train the journey itself
was relatively normal i mean ukraine
railways have been doing an amazing job
at keeping this country going the
civilian effort both by getting aid into
places that desperately need it as well
as bringing people out of those hotspot
areas
there were a couple of amendments if you
will the blinds needed to be closed for
the entire journey at night when as soon
as the sun went down all the blinds had
to be closed so that you're less visible
from the sky
and the train also travels at a much
slower pace it took almost twice as long
as the normal journey because if
anything does
happen you know there's any kind of
shelling or anything like that the train
needs to be able to stop to evacuate the
passengers
incredible details there rebecca thank
you so much rebecca rebecca ritter
speaking to us from lev in western
ukraine
and let's get some more developments in
the war there
austrian chancellor khan emma is to meet
the russian leader vladimir putin in
moscow he'll be the first european
leader to do so since the invasion of
ukraine nehamer has been in kiev where
he offered humanitarian aid and
political support
a grave containing at least two
civilians has been uncovered in busova
village near kiev it's the latest burial
site identified since russian forces
withdrew from the area to concentrate on
eastern ukraine
the airport in nepal ukraine's fourth
biggest city has been badly damaged by
russian missile attacks that's according
to the local governor
thick columns of smoke could be seen
rising around the airport
you